imagination can only take you so far so
what I'm going to talk about here I had
actually considered doing this
specifically as a Doctor Who
centered video because these are
thoughts that I've had about Chris
Chibnall being the showrunner for a
female doctor and I thought about just
focusing in on that but I kind of want
to talk about it in broader strokes in
general on a more philosophical level
than just sort of hammering in on the on
this one thing and I want to talk about
when writers write outside of their
experience and the reason my initial
thoughts were to talk Doctor Who is
because we obviously now have a female
doctor and I found myself wondering you
know the idea of a female doctor was one
that I was initially it's very skeptical
of and I'm you know I'm not worried
about that inherently anymore I mean I
still have my worries about a new series
because I would be worried about any new
actor with a new field runner coming in
so but I did find myself wondering when
the time came to do a female doctor
would it have been a better idea to have
a female showrunner a female head writer
because when people write outside of
their own core experience things can
sometimes go awry now before I get into
some examples of what I'm talking about
let me begin by saying that I am NOT
laying out some kind of thing where like
you can only write what you know if you
don't if you don't have a first-hand
experience you can't write about it I
would never tell any writer of any
format whether it be television books
comic books movies whatever that they
can't write a certain kind of character
of course you can anybody can take
crack at writing anything I do believe
that but there are certain pitfalls and
certain traps that I see come up
repeatedly
when people attempt to write a character
that is distinctly unlike themselves in
their experience so obviously the idea
of male of men writing female characters
and you know white people write black
people and you know cisgender people
writing trans characters anything like
that and again this is not a case of
like every time somebody steps outside
their experience they get it wrong no
there are ton of instances of you know
men writing women extremely well of
white people writing black characters
from you all black writers writing white
characters extremely well black writers
writing white characters extremely well
but going through these is making my
tongue just read out fail me but you get
what I'm saying like there are tons of
businesses of this working so don't act
me all the times that this works I just
want to talk about the pitfalls that
happen and that I sometime and when I
try to point these out I do sometimes
get pushback of like oh are you saying I
can't write it no write whatever you
want but when something is outside of
your experience that should be done with
a little bit more care and ideally a
little bit more research so some of the
things that come to mind the podcasts
that I do with my partner Liz now called
tough like a girl we had to rename it
for a very stupid reason but we covered
Thor goddess of thunder the first trade
collected trade volume of that and it
was good actually it's quite good but
there is something that happens and I
think the actual issue had happened it
was five it was four or five I think it
was five we're the new Thor who's now a
woman confronts the absorbing man and
titania and it's an okay action beat
but there are bits of it that are really
really cringey because well for a couple
things the the writer decided to turn
absorbent man into a straw man for
people who were criticizing the idea of
a female Thor in the first place which
is a bit of a cheap go at people but
even as that goes on you know there's
all this emphasis that you know that
this villain is putting on oh you know
why'd you have to take a guy's title
Thor was his name like what the heck and
then titania she you know decides to not
fight Thor because Thor's a woman now
and like look I'll just I'll I'll just
give in this time as a like a mark of
sisterhood and it's a really awkward
scene it's really weird and again not to
say that a woman would be incapable of
writing that but when I've come across
stuff like that it's always been men
writing women or another example you
know to step outside my usual geek
wheelhouse my daughter's mother read a
fair amount of James Patterson books
specifically the Alex Cross series so
things like along came a spider kissed
the girls she read Moses and I am at
least you know back in the mid-2000s
however many were out up to that point
so but she pointed out to me how much
how she could have made a drinking game
out of the a certain phrase that kept
turning up over and over and over and
over again which is and and again if you
didn't know the character of Alex Cross
is black that's the lead in these books
the author James Patterson is white
again there is not a problem with that
but she said she could have made a
drinking game out of how many times the
phrase I was the only black man in the
room or some equivalent there
just some pointing out of that got done
over and over and over and over again
and it's not like that's an irrelevant
thing to point out but once you've
established that he's out of his element
in terms of his place here you don't
have to keep repointing it out again and
again and again and again and these are
the traps that I think writers fall into
when not only are they writing outside
their experience but they know they are
and they kind of overstep and over
complicate and overthink oh my god I
need to address the fact I need to
address this stuff you know so you know
was something like Thor like oh man
I'm a guy writing this female character
I got to be sure I make her super ultra
strong female character and really put
emphasis emphasis on it you know as much
as I love a lot of these things that
I've seen it turn up in that girl I've
seen it turn up in Buffy stuff where you
know there's this really over emphasis
on girl power not just having it like
females with strength but like labeling
it girl power
having it pointed out by characters man
women are tough I almost never see that
when a woman writes these characters
because they'll just write them as tough
and let it stand whereas I think you
know and I've mentioned this before but
I mean I have aspirations as a fiction
writer so so I understand you know the
insecurities that you can get in trying
to write characters you know you want to
be sure that everybody gets what it is
you're doing that people see the effort
you put into it but highlighting it like
that just makes it weird and awkward and
cringy because like to contrast
something like that for
scene with say Ms marvel Kamala Khan I
love her book so much and what's and I
think part of the reason that it is
written as accessible as it is and that
these characters come off as genuine as
they do is because the writer G willow
Wilson is herself a Muslim and she's
writing Muslim characters now again is
that a my does that mean that a
Christian writer couldn't write them
just as well or an atheist or anything
no absolutely not but the thing is that
she was able to draw directly from her
own well of knowledge and of experience
and present these characters in a
fully-formed way whereas someone who has
to you know either yeah if they're good
about it do a lot of research or if
they're lazy about it make a heck of a
lot of presumptions they would they
would be pouring all these facts they'd
be CRO barring in these things and not
necessarily knowing how they actually
you know because you can do research but
it's hard to know how the facts of
something like living a Muslim life and
growing up in a Muslim family how those
actually play out in a living situation
I mean you can look up the you know the
practices or whatever you need drop your
references to them and you know if
you're if you overdo it really highlight
that you put them in there but
integrating them into a natural flow
where it just feels like an element of
the characters that is much easier to do
when you write what you know and you
write characters with backgrounds
similar to yours now again that is not
me saying that people should not be
writing outside your experience you
absolutely should but I think it's just
very typical for a write or any writer
of any background religion gender
sexuality
- just overdue trying to encapsulate
that experience and then it just comes
across as artificial and forests and
wooden and to bring it back to Doctor
Who again that has been part of my worry
that will a man writing the doctor as a
woman put more emphasis on that fact
than an actual woman would and I don't
know if this will be the case with Chris
Chibnall I only hope not but my
inclination from my reading and viewing
experiences that yeah probably that I
think it is more likely that a male
writer will highlight the fact that
she's a woman whereas I think it is more
likely that a female head writer would
simply have her be a woman and let it
speak for itself and that's the big
thing writing outside your experience
the the tenants of what makes
conversations flow the story moves
smoothly and what makes characters have
depth is the truest it remains true no
matter what whether you're writing
within your experience or outside of it
so tacking extra stuff on can disrupt
the flow of your process and then it
just - rails the whole thing so I don't
have a final concluding point that I'm
making here but I just kind of wanna I
just kind of wanted to work my way and
talk my way through the thoughts that
have been going through my head recently
and certainly was something I Doctor Who
I really hope that this is an unfounded
fear because like I said I I don't think
it I I would never say that Chris
Chibnall that any head writer should be
hired because they were a woman and they
have a female doctor well no as you get
someone who's gonna handle the character
in the story in the show well but
this is one of the reasons why I think
it's important to have diversity in your
writing room in the development process
of more movies of more comic books of
more TV shows because if nothing else
even if you know the head writer or show
creator what have you is stepping
outside their own experience if they can
turn to like literally just terms it was
like oh oh help me you know someone who
has the experience I think that makes a
difference
and it's been helpful you know that he
does seem to have a I would say a
respectable percentage of females on the
writing staff and also hired to direct
the episodes now again does that
automatically mean it will be better
well no Jessica Jones season 2 kind of
made a big song and dance about how
every episode was directed by a woman
that didn't make that season any better
it was a nice thought but that won't
automatically save it any more than
having a female character her handle by
man will automatically ruin it
I just think that it's it's a place
where diversity within the development
process the creative process benefits
everybody because you end up with a
situation where it's much easier to
include greater diversity because you
can turn to someone with the experience
so that it can be integrated naturally
and flow the way a good character or a
good moment should so there we go
how many pervs are gonna call me an sjw
because I ended up unexpectedly making
this a call for diversity I honestly
hadn't planned to go there but that's
where my head went so we'll see but if
you can if you've got any thoughts on
any of this even if you disagree with me
go ahead leave something in the comics
keep it respectful even if you do
disagree with me please
but drop something out in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do like there's
buttons and there's links and there's oh
my goodness there's all kinds of stuff
down there check it out there's a
patreon and just remember folks you are
the council
and I just run the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]